[Applaudissements]
personne pour expliquer ce qu'est ce
qu'on fait des commentaires j'ai pas
bête non viril à chaque mot est pesé et
enfin le son avocat lui a fait dire très
exactement le poids en direct je pense
que tout est pesé tout est calibré et
nora qu'elle est a envie de le faire je
le conçois pas vraiment qu'on la laisse
faire
moi ça me choque pourquoi parce qu coupe
faim comme l'a dit thierry ac
donc c'est la production était une fois
qui vous choque mais complètement à quel
moment cette personne mais il ajouté
dans les règles enfin la prochaine dit
pas l'inversé
mais après ou pas au chacun ici donne
son avis moi j'étais pas à l'aise je me
suis dit en tout cas j'espère qu'elle se
rend compte de la chance et du privilège
qu'elle a contrario d'autres noms suis
sûr qu'elle se rend compte et qu'elle se
rencontreront de ce privilège qui est de
s'exprimer comme ça avant ce procès moi
c'est vrai que je préfère les
témoignages un peu fort et utiles comme
les conjoints des victimes des attentats
oui mais mais effectivement l'interview
était mignon il faut de tout c'était
millions et surtout très très bien
maîtrisé et qui avait au lit campagne de
com pour vendre son bouquin et thierry
demaizière il est il déjà mais je trouve
qu'il ait jamais voyeuriste voilà
j'avais en direct il n'est jamais trop
tard c'est surréaliste on assistait
quelques chez au public en france et sur
un an mais si on les laissait donc finir
j